today on the Matt Walsh show a
whistleblower from inside the child
gender transition industry has finally
come forward and what she reveals is
horrifying I'll walk you through the
whole story today also a congressional
Democrat learns that the old yelling
fire in a crowded theater Trope is not
actually a valid argument against free
speech
um I have one more clip that you haven't
seen yet from that now Infamous
Committee hearing in Tennessee that'll
play for you plus reports suggest that
project Veritas is trying to push James
O'Keefe out even though James O'Keefe is
Project Veritas and our daily
cancellation Vice holds a panel
discussion on race one guy with common
sense somehow made it onto the panel and
proceeds to offend and terrify the rest
of them it's pretty hilarious we'll talk
about all that and more today the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ERS have taught us anything it's that in
a crisis like a global pandemic or a
natural disaster even the basics can be
hard to come by and that's why you need
to be prepared for anything my new
partners at Jace medical are here to
help Jace Medical's mission is to
empower you to be better medically
prepared even in the worst case
scenarios great way to start preparing
is with the Jace case a pack of five
different courses of antibiotics that
you can use to treat a whole host of
bacterial illnesses including UTIs
respiratory infections skin infections
and much more
um all you have to do is fill out a
simple online form and in some cases
jump on a quick call with one of their
board certified Physicians from there
you can ask your physician treatment
related questions on an ongoing basis
and I know that I find this very useful
especially with the you know six kids
now you never know even if it's not a a
a pandemic or a earthquake or something
there are other emergencies that can
crop up every day when you have kids and
that's why the Jace case gives me peace
of mind knowing that my family will have
what we need if the worst happens I want
you to be prepared for anything so go to
jsemedical.com enter code wall should
check out for a discount on your order
that's at jacemedical.com promo code
Walsh
in the fight against gender ideology and
the abuse of Mutilation of children we
have been operating at a disadvantage
while the many disadvantages you know
the institutions are against us the
elites and corporate interests and
nearly everyone with power is against us
most of the platforms that we use to
spread our message are hostile to the
message and to us and the activists on
the other side are empowered to act with
impunity defaming us threatening us
without any consequence they're also
evil to their core and beholden to lies
which means that they not only are
allowed to do and say whatever they want
but also are willing to do or say
anything
all of these are disadvantages for for a
team sanity but in spite of these
obstacles our team team sanity has made
enormous Headway recently every every
battle is stacked against us and yet we
have had some tremendous victories both
against the ideology and against the
mutilation industry specifically
yet all of these hurdles create another
and especially significant one is that
we haven't been able to get access to
anyone on the inside of that industry
the mutilation industry we've heard from
former patients who've been mutilated
and butchered and are now speaking out
they're drugged and abused and are
talking about it we've heard from
doctors who've been around this industry
who who have seen how it operates and
are appropriately horrified by it many
people in the orbit of this industry or
who have fallen victim to it have taken
a stand against it
but up until this point the the uh the
threats veiled and otherwise and the
fear of social alienation
has been enough to prevent any actual
whistleblowers from inside the child
mutilation industry from coming forward
at least publicly you know I personally
have heard from medical professionals on
the inside
who are sickened by what they've seen by
what they themselves have done
and what by and and by what they
themselves continue to do but none of
them have been willing to speak publicly
and put their name on it that the
potential the certainty really of their
lives as they know them being torn apart
is simply too much for them to Bear they
don't have the courage to do the right
thing and bear the cost of that decision
and so the child mutilation industry the
gender industry as a whole has been able
to remain at least from a public facing
perspective insular and closed off
it has not had any whistleblowers
until now
yesterday a website called The Free
Press published an article by a woman
named Jamie Reed and what you should
know about Reed is that she spent four
years as a case manager at the
Washington University transgender Center
at St Louis Children's Hospital
she also identifies herself as quote
queer and says that she is married to a
quote trans man
point being this is certainly not a
conservative with any sort of political
acts to grind
and and she's been on the inside of this
gender ideology World in just about
every way possible professionally and
personally
and now she's had enough
she explains in the article
quote I left the clinic in November of
last year because I could no longer
participate in what was happening there
by the time I departed I was certain
that the way the American Medical system
is treating these patients is the
opposite of the promise we make to do no
harm instead we are permanently harming
the vulnerable patients in our care
today I am speaking out I am doing so
knowing how toxic the public
conversation is around this highly
contentious issue and the ways that my
testimony might be misused I am doing so
knowing that I am putting myself in
serious personal and professional risk
almost everyone in my life has advised
me to keep my head down but I cannot in
good conscience do so because what is
happening to scores of children is far
more important than my comfort and what
is happening to them is morally and
medically appalling
now from here read documents in great
detail
what exactly went on in this Clinic
what she reveals can leave no doubt that
not only are these clinics harming
children irrevocably and brutally
but that they know they are harming
children and they do it anyway
I'm going to read some of the passages
to you I'll be doing a lot more reading
than I would normally do in an opening
monologue but it's um it's more
important that you hear from Jamie Reed
than from me today so this is this is uh
we'll go through this and kind of
um get as much of the whole story as we
can
so she continues soon after my arrival
at the transgender Center I was struck
by the lack of formal protocols for
treatment the center's physician
co-directors were essentially the sole
Authority at first the patient
population was tipped toward what used
to be the traditional instance of a
child with gender dysphoria a boy often
quite young who wanted to be wanted to
present as who wanted to be a girl until
2015 or so a very small number of these
boys comprise the population of
pediatric gender dysphoria cases then
Across the Western World there began to
be a dramatic increase in a new
population teenage girls many with no
previous history of gender distress
suddenly declared they were transgender
and demanded immediate treatment with
testosterone I certainly saw this at the
center one of my jobs was to do intake
for new patients and their families
when I started there were probably 10
such calls a month when I left there
were 50.
and about 70 percent of the new patients
were girls sometimes clusters of girls
arrived from the same High School
now next she explains how most of their
female patients had comorbidities most
of them were psychological combivity so
they've been diagnosed with anxiety or
depression or ADHD many of them have had
diagnosed with autism and there have
also been studies that are showing that
this is it's very very common this
correlation between kids who are
diagnosed autistic and then next thing
you know they're saying they have gender
dysphoria
but lots of them declared lots of lots
of them apparently declared that they
had other disorders that were entirely
in their heads so she said that they
would um that these girls they would
frequently claim to have things like
Tourette's Syndrome or multiple
personality disorder
but it was all imaginary they didn't
have that
Reed says that the doctors of the clinic
recognized that many of these disorders
the girls had invented and they were
actually symptoms of social contagions
they'd been they'd been uh convinced by
their friends by the internet that they
had Tourette so they had multiple
personalities but they didn't
and yet these same doctors she says were
not willing to admit or even consider
that gender dysphoria is also one of
these social contagions
just like all the other social contagion
disorders that these girls had fallen
prey to
Reed continues to begin transitioning
the girls needed a letter of support
from a therapist usually one we
recommended
who they had to see only once or twice
for the green light to make it more
efficient for the therapist we offered
them a template for how to write a
letter to of support for transition the
next stop was a single visit to the
endocrinologist for a testosterone
prescription and that's all it took when
a female takes testosterone the profound
and permanent effects of the hormone can
be seen in a matter of months voices
drop beards Sprout body fat is
redistributed sexual interest explodes
aggression increases and mood can be
unpredictable our patients were told
about some side effects including
sterility but after working at the
center I came to believe the teenagers
are simply not capable of fully grasping
what it means to make the decision to
become infertile while still minors
well of course they can't grasp that
as I've said many times you know uh it's
obviously minors obviously kids
can't
grasp uh the consequence of you know
choosing to be infertile or choosing to
be sterile they're giving up the
possibility of having kids at a time
when
they can't they couldn't know what that
means
and there are many people even in their
early 20s I was one of these people my
early even in my early 20s
uh I I couldn't
really imagine what it would be like to
have kids you know it wasn't something
that I thought about
a few years later I had kids
so as for all what all this means Reed
explains quote many encounters with
patients emphasized to me how little
these young people understood the
profound impact changing gender would
have on their bodies and minds but the
center downplayed the negative
consequences and emphasized the need for
transition as the Center's website said
quote left untreated gender dysphoria
has any number of consequences from
self-harm to Suicide but when you take
away the gender dysphoria by allowing a
child to be who he or she is we're
noticing that goes away the studies we
have we have show these kids often wind
up functioning psychosocially as well or
as or better than their peers
but there are no reliable studies
showing this read writes indeed the
experiences of many of the center's
patients prove how false these
assertions are here's an example
on Friday May 1st 2020 a colleague
emailed me about a 15 year old male
patient
email said quote Oh dear I am concerned
that the patient does not understand
what bichel Michael
udemite I think does it's medicine I
responded
I don't think we start anything honestly
right now Michael mutilite is a is a
medication used to treat metastic
prostate cancer and one of its side
effects is that it feminizes the bodies
of men who take it including the
appearance of breasts the center
prescribed this cancer drug as a puberty
blocker and feminizing agent for boys
as with most Cancer drugs this drug has
a long list of side effects and the
patient experienced one of them this
patient did which is liver toxicity he
was sent to another unit of the hospital
for evaluation and immediately taken off
the drug afterwards his mother sent an
electronic message to the transgender
Center saying that we were lucky her
family was not the type to sue
Reed also documents a case of a 17 year
old girl on testosterone who experienced
bleeding from the vagina that became so
heavy that she had to be rushed to the
emergency room it turns out that the
girl
though transitioning to become a boy was
still having vaginal intercourse but
that activity combined with the
testosterone led to a severe vaginal
lacerations and Reed says that this girl
was not the only case of this kind that
she saw
more from Reed she writes other girls
were disturbed by the effects of
testosterone on their clitoris which
enlarges and grows into what looks like
a micro phallus or a tiny penis a
counseled one patient who's a large
clitoris now extended below her vulva
and it chafed and rubbed painfully in
her jeans I advised her to get the kind
of compression undergarments worn by
biological men who dressed to pass as
female at the end of the call I thought
to myself wow we hurt this kid
there are rare conditions in babies uh
with babies that are born with atypical
genitalia cases that call for
sophisticated care and compassion but
clinics like the one where I worked are
creating a whole cohort of kids with
atypical genitals and most of these kids
haven't even had sex yet they had no
idea who they were going to be as adults
yet all it took for them to permanently
transform themselves was one or two
short conversations with a therapist
Reed says that sometimes the the parents
would only come to to understand what
they'd consented to on behalf of their
children after the fact so she shares
one email from a distraught parent and
uh the email says please be advised that
I'm revoking my consent for this course
of medical treatment grades have dropped
there's been an inpatient Behavioral
Health visit and now he's on five
different medications Lexapro trazodone
boost Buspar whatever that I pronounce
Etc he's a shell of his former self
riddled with anxiety who knows if it's
because of the blockers or other
medications I revoke my consent I want
the hormone blocker removed thank you
Reed also reveals that the transgender
clinic at St Louis Children's Hospital
would keep itself stocked with new
patients through referrals from the
psychiatric ward at the same Hospital
so kids who are diagnosed with
schizophrenia or you know bipolar
disorder were funneled through the
transgender clinic and then given
diagnoses of gender dysphoria as well
and then put on these experimental
transitional uh you know transition
treatments she mentions one especially
disturbing case
quote for example
one teenager came to us in the summer of
2022 when he was 17 years old and living
in a lockdown facility because he had
been he had been sexually abusing dogs
he'd had an awful childhood his mother
was a drug addict his father was
imprisoned then he grew up in foster
care whatever treatment he may have been
getting it wasn't working during our
intake I learned from another caseworker
that when he got out he planned to
reoffend because he believed the dogs
had willingly submitted
somewhere along the line he expressed a
desire to become female so he ended up
being seen at our center from there he
went to a psychologist at the hospital
who was known to approve virtually
everyone seeking transition then our
doctor recommended feminizing hormones
at the time I wondered if this was being
done as a form of chemical castration
well it's always a form of chemical
castration so the answer to that is yes
and then there's the issue of parental
consent Reed explains how the clinic
would undermine or manipulate the
parents because you know in theory the
parents have to consent to this
which obviously even if they do consent
to it it doesn't remotely make any of
this okay
but what you find out is is that is that
even parental consent many times is not
really consent because they themselves
are being manipulated this was
especially easy as she explains to do in
cases where the parents disagreed about
the transition
and the clinic of course would always
side with whichever parents wanted to
transition the child and history would
seem to indicate that the parent who
wants to transition the child is like
almost always the mother so she recounts
one case
well my concerns about this approach to
dissenting parents grew in 2019 when one
of our doctors actually testified in a
custody hearing against a father who
opposed A Mother's wish to start their
11 year old daughter on puberty blockers
I had done the original intake call and
I found the mother quite disturbing she
and the father were getting divorced and
the mother described the daughter as
kind of a tomboy
so now the mother was convinced her
child was trans
but when I asked if her daughter had
adopted a boy's name if she was
distressed about her body if she was
saying she felt like a boy the mother
said no I explained the girl just didn't
meet the criteria for an evaluation then
a month later the mother called back and
said her daughter now used a boy's name
and was in distress over her body and
wanted to transition this time the mom
and daughter were given an appointment
our providers decided the girl was trans
and prescribed a puberty blocker to
prevent her normal development the
father adamantly disagreed said that
this was all coming from the mother and
a custody battle ensued after the
hearing where our doctor testified in
favor of transition the judge sided with
the mother
of course he did
it's not all at all hard to interpret
what happened here obviously the girl
was an innocent normal child
maybe a bit of a tomboy okay and the
mother decided that she wanted the girl
to be trans this is what she wanted
perhaps partially fueled by her
resentment against the husband that she
was divorcing like you see this is very
very common as I said that you got two
parents that disagree and it's almost
always the mother I'm not a I'm not
saying this has never happened but I'm
not aware of a single case
where parents disagree on transition and
it's the father insisting on it and the
mother saying no again maybe that
happens
every case I've ever heard it's always
the mom
um and so the mother then learned you
know she called the the clinic and she
learned what she needs to say to get
drugs for her daughter
and then called the clinic back reading
from that script and now this abusive
Munchausen mommy who is poisoning her
daughter
has custody of the child because the
judge decided that the daughter is
safest with the parent who wants to
poison her
this is the world we live in
but it's a world that I believe
can change
and that we can change and we are
changing
you know we can put a stop to this kind
of child abuse we can defeat the child
mutilators completely and bring down the
entire industry Nationwide
I believe that
we are winning this fight and now with
whistleblowers finally coming forward
um I I have hope that some sort of dam
is breaking
because what they're doing to kids is so
straightforwardly evil so unthinkably
brutal and deranged and barbaric
so thoroughly indefensible that it
cannot be sustained the edifice is weak
and vulnerable and and we can tear it
all down and we will I truly believe
that
but
the job isn't even close to finish yet
there's a lot more to do
and we can't stop until it's done
now let's get to our headlines
experts are highlighting new identity
theft threats to watch for 2023 some
tactics include scams targeting specific
ethnic groups and those with limited
English proficiency payment app scams
will likely continue to increase as
their popularity increase that's why
it's so important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day your
personal information gets exposed so
often that it's dangerously easy for a
cyber criminal to steal your identity
but protecting your identity can be easy
with LifeLock by Norton LifeLock detects
and alerts you to potential identity
threats so you may not be able to spot
on your own like loans taken out in your
name if you do become a victim of
identity theft
a dedicated U.S based restoration
specialist will work to help you fix it
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but it's easy to help protect
yourself with Lifelock Identity Theft
Protection Starts Here join now and save
up 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com Walsh that's LifeLock dot
com slash Walsh for 25 percent off
just from CNN the GOP LEDs select house
select subcommittee on so-called
weaponization of the federal government
at a little they had a little
editorialization in there of course with
the phrase so-called uh you know the
so-called weaponization of the federal
government well it's not so called I
mean we call it that yes but that's
because that's exactly what's happening
with the federal government
um anyway it's drawing Upon A prominent
ex-democrat two of the Republican Senate
colleagues and a former FBI agent in
their first public hearing to discuss
how they believe the government has been
weaponized against conservatives
multiple sources familiar with the plans
tell CNN
um and so this this uh panel uh or this
Committee hearing been a lot of
committee here a lot of news about
committee hearings this week
and uh and usually committee hearings
are pretty boring but there have been
some interesting moments including at
this one so this was again Committee
hearing about the weaponization of the
federal government
and there was one Exchange
that I thought was uh interesting this
is between Jonathan Turley and a
Democrat representative Daniel Goldman
Goldman wanted to explain why
he wanted to make the case for why the
federal government needs to suppress
speech sometimes and so he brought up
the old you know the old uh the old
cliche about fire in a crowded theater
and here's how that exchange went it's
the first amendment protect someone from
yelling fire in a movie theater
fortunately that one is not yes or no
because that's become a mantra for
people it's the homes uh shank uh line
Holmes himself walk back on all right
homes and we don't need a law class here
um so but but you do agree though don't
you that the First Amendment does not
protect all speech
no there are limits to speech all
constitutional rights have limits that's
uh that's great that's got shades of the
uh we asked the questions here that I
got at the Committee hearing I was
justifying from uh it's well we don't
need a law class you asked him a legal
question and he got he got he got a good
legal answer but he wasn't the answer he
liked so whoa we don't need a lock last
year you nerd
we weren't asking for all that
um by the way fire in a crowded theater
this was a as Jonathan Charlie was
indicating this is this is a phrase used
by a Supreme Court Justice in a case
like uh it's like 100 years ago which
and in that that case which which found
that anti-war activists don't have the
right to protest I actually found that
that uh you know anti-war protest is not
protected speech um but that case was
then partially overturned in 1969. so
it's it's essentially a legal rationale
that was always absurd and has long
since been made moot
because as it turns out you can yell
fire in a crowded theater
right
uh you can do that
um
now if you want
to even like begin to try to penalize
someone for yelling fire in a crowded
theater then there would have to be a
bunch of conditions met
like was was uh first of all was
somebody harmed
by the fact that someone directly yelled
fire and cut at theater and there was uh
and there was a a big you know mob
people running out and then someone was
hurt did that happen like that would
need to happen first of all
um you didn't need to prove that it was
done maliciously so even in the literal
case of someone yelling fire in crowded
theater
there are a whole bunch of conditions
uh that would need to be met before
there's any chance of it if it you know
of any kind of criminal charges or
misdemeanor charges being filed
but here's here's the big thing here's
why this this analogy doesn't work also
this this is the main thing
is that
obviously
everyone would agree that you there's
certainly nothing wrong legally or
morally
with yelling fire in a crowded theater
if there actually is a fire
right so the first thing if it can only
begin to be wrong to yell it if there is
no fire and then we got to go through
all the other things right like what did
you do did you yelled fire did you know
that there wasn't a fire were you doing
it maliciously did it actually cause
direct you know physical harm all those
things
but if there is a fire
then not only can you yell fire in a
crowded theater but you'll be very wrong
if you didn't
if you if you saw the fire
and no one else notices it and you see
it starting in the corner of the room
and you just get up and pack your stuff
and walk out of the um of the theater
and leave everyone to burn to death
well then you might have some liability
in that case because you didn't say
anything
or at least you should
so when you bring this and when you
bring this over into the realm of
metaphor
because when they bring up fire to
crowded theater we're not actually
talking about people literally yelling
fire to crowded theater they're drawing
an analogy they're comparing it to
something
um yet you would need to to prove that
the metaphorical fire isn't there so you
know here's here's a here's a a time
when they often use this a a personal
example
when they use it against me or against
people that are you know anti-um
anti-child mutilation
when we when we describe what's what we
just heard you know we just heard from
The Whistleblower what's happening
because when we describe that as child
abuse or child mutilation
well the other side they say oh this is
you're yelling fire to crowded
theater
you know if one of these child
mutilators which they would if one of
these uh gender affirming doctors gets
hurt
well then it's your fault
well yeah that's because you are
claiming that the fire isn't there but
it but it is see the fire is actually
there in this case
we're calling them child mutilators but
they are
and so very clearly we are allowed to
point that out because it is actually
happening
so this is a case where
um
they want us to ignore the fire they
can't deny the fire is there because it
is
but what they're telling us is that we
have to keep our mouth shut and just let
everyone burn to death only in this case
it's not you know it's not the people in
the theater burning to death it's it's
kids
we have to we have to keep our mouth
shut and let the the children be
incinerated
so as not to yell fire
no
um
we could put all the complicated legal
discussions to the side and simply
establish that if there is actually a
fire not only can you yell it but you
damn well better
there was one other moment from
the Committee hearing that I attended on
Wednesday that I want to share with you
and this one isn't quite as explosive as
one it doesn't involve me this is uh but
it was it was it was also interesting
but keep in mind it was right after they
asked me questions first and then uh and
then you know they weren't really
questions but they were just using it as
an opportunity to like try to uh
uh assassinate my character and all that
and they were done with that uh because
they were tired of me answering them and
they couldn't trap me and then they
brought a an actual doctor up uh and
started questioning him and this is a
doctor who is who is anti-child
mutilation he's on the right he's in the
pro-sanity side of it
and they tried the same credentialism
thing on him in fact the exact same guy
the exact same legislator tried it on
him the same thing they did to me but
listen to how this went
what was your are you a pediatric what
was your specialty doctor
I am board certified and I can't even
talk Obstetrics and Gynecology as well
as family medicine with a focus on
sports medicine as well
the representative Clemens no
Endocrinology or Pediatrics well
Pediatrics is part of Family Medicine
family medicine and then also with
regards to Endocrinology that's a big
portion of what we do In Obstetrics and
Gynecology and what's your formal
training in that
four years of medical school and
residency with oral and written boards
and continued maintenance and
certification you recognize do you do
any residency in the Endocrinology yeah
thanking them
thank you uh by the way that doctors
Omar Hamada he gave me his card uh and
we'll let you know because this is this
that's this is one of the good ones this
is one of the good guys in the medical
field but it's just it's great because
it's the same
again the same guy that tried that with
with me now he brings a doctor up and
what he's trying to do he's doing the
credentialism thing and he's he's trying
to prove that Dr Hamada's views don't
count because he doesn't have the he
doesn't check the right credential boxes
but every but but every box he presents
Dr Amada does check it so he has to keep
getting more and more specific well you
don't do pediatrics do you well actually
that's part of family medicine but what
about you what's your experience in
endocrinology oh yeah well we work with
that all the time uh but did you do a
residency in endocrinology well no I
didn't do that thank you no more
questions
you keep getting more and more specific
because no matter what he brought up
it's he it checked the box and then
you notice at the end of that there was
no follow-up question it wasn't leading
anywhere
it's like let me just find the one
slight you've been you've been working
in in medicine you've been working in
the field for years and years and years
you are definitely an expert in this
subject
but let me find the one little Gap the
one supposed Gap that I can find and uh
and I'll call attention to that and
that'll be the end of it
foreign because as it turns out
um
they do the credentialism thing
but it doesn't actually matter obviously
because
I can get up there and I didn't even go
to college
and so they say well it doesn't get your
opinion doesn't count you didn't even go
to college
and then a guy who's been in the medical
field for decades could get up there and
he's got all kinds of relevant
experience but he doesn't matter it
doesn't count for him either
because whether you have the credentials
or not
the only credential that actually
matters to these people is whether you
agree with them that is the only thing
they care about
which is also why you notice they never
do the credentialism thing with someone
on their side
there were other people at the hearing
who spoke up in favor of child
mutilation and were not doctors okay and
yet for some reason they weren't called
up and asked about their credentials
nobody called them up and said well what
are you what's your expertise
because as long as you agree with the
party line
um that is the one single credential
that matters that's it
another quick update on that by the way
uh representative Caleb hemmer we talked
about yesterday he was the guy that
tried the Media Matters hit piece on me
and then uh and then I asked him one
simple question and he you know
he uh recoiled and horror and fell
silent and totally humiliated himself
and you know yesterday on the show we
played the clip and I uh did encourage
the sweet baby gang to provide feedback
to this elected official
um because I assumed
and this is the truth I just honestly
assume that he's an elected official and
he would really want to hear feedback
from his constituents and even people
who aren't his constituents uh just from
just from Americans and taxpayers I
figured he'd really want to hear that I
was really trying to do him a favor
but it turns out that he didn't want to
hear anyone's feedback because
um as of this morning representative
Caleb hemmer had removed all the contact
information from his website he took it
all down
I'm not sure if that's even legal
you know we would need to get a I don't
have the credentials as a lawyer need to
get a lawyer in here but as a as a
elected representative can you just take
down your contact information
can you remove it so that your
constituents can't contact you
um
obviously this went a certain way and
it's not how Caleb hemmer had planned
you know he thought here's what he
planned here's what he thought I don't
think he thought this through all the
way but what he was planning was that I
would get up there and he would have his
hit piece
and he presented to me and then I guess
he assumed that I would say oh you're
right I uh well you know what I'm really
sorry
about well I'm very I'm just very sorry
and I um and uh and I I I will back away
now and I will I guess that's what he
expected expect me to apologize and bow
my head solemnly and then walk away
and then he would have that moment and
he could brag about he could post it
it'd be beautiful didn't go that way
instead he humiliated himself
um and then he had a whole bunch of
people trying to contact him to give
feedback that was probably quite
negative and then I went on Tucker
Carlson last night and Tucker played
that clip and had some uh very critical
things to say about representative Caleb
hemmer by name
and so now his whole world is like
falling down on top of him
not how he thought it would go
but here's the thing if you try to
defame me
uh if you try to use lazy hit pieces on
me if you try to lay a trap for me and
you do it all
in an effort to protect child butchers
then this is going to be the response
okay you're good you're there's gonna be
a consequence for that
so go ahead and take your shot
give your best effort
um and then it's going to be my turn and
so you're learning that Caleb
I don't think you quite understand like
what time it is here
and what kind of conservatives and what
version of the right you're dealing with
um this is and I know maybe you you know
you're you're used to the version of the
right the old right where
you kind of go along and you controlled
opposition and you play your part and
that's not the case here
um we don't go along with the game and
bow down dismissively like We're Playing
for Keeps
so get your head in the game next time
buddy
speaking of trans issues uh here's
someone trying to work out how to feel
about being misgendered I thought this
was kind of interesting
so I was just picking up my vehicle from
an oil change and the person came out of
the garage and said what can I do for
you young lady and I know that this was
intended to be a greeting of respect and
kindness or politeness maybe but I had
this immediate like okay young maybe
comparatively I'll take it but I was
like lady what do I do with that like
it's so complicated because I know this
person only intended kindness there was
a smile on their face like I knew that
they weren't trying to like patronize me
or gender me but I felt so gendered and
so inappropriately gendered and I don't
know what to do with that like what do
you do with that when someone like has
the best of intentions and I don't
really want to spend all of my spoons
trying to educate someone at the Costco
car center
what do you do with that uh what you do
with that is you live your life
um you move on and you live your life
and you leave Costco
and uh and that's it
that's what you do with that
these people they they are they are
uh
they fall into the state of like
paralysis
after just
normal polite interactions they feel
like they have to analyze all of that
and in every every interaction that they
have every interaction they have with
anyone is loaded every interaction it's
a loaded interaction and uh nothing can
just there's no such thing in this in
the world of this kind of person
there's no such thing as just a polite
normal interaction you and I as normal
sane people we have those that that's
mostly interactions we have in Life or
just with like people acquaintances you
passable industry you say you know you
say hello to someone and that's it
that's most of the people you meet it's
that's easy there's no reason to even
think about it
that doesn't exist for these people that
are um
you know but that's also the consequence
of believing that you are the center of
the universe and everything that happens
is extremely significant and everyone
who talks to you has to talk to you a
certain way and approach you a certain
way and if they don't then it's this
traumatic moment in your life
this is the consequence all right one
other thing I wanted to mention
a very odd and I think troubling story
and I don't know I can't make heads or
tails but I don't know exactly what to
make of it but this is from Newsweek
James O'Keefe the founder of the
controversial right-wing video
organization project Veritas has taken
paid leave from the company with his
future currently in doubt according to
an internal message to project Veritas
employees sent by the organization's
executive director Daniel Strack seen by
the New York Magazine's Intelligencer
website O'Keefe is taking a few weeks
off of well-deserved paid time off the
message did not expand upon while the
founder of of the undercover artist
group is on leave in the company in a
further statement Strack said
like all newsrooms at this stage the
project Veritas board of directors and
management are constantly evaluating
what the best best path forward is for
the organization
um now as initially is what they said
they said I was just taking leave we
don't know exactly what's going on
and then uh
a leaked memo
came out which reveals that project Fair
test employees have raised concerns
about his behavior to the board the memo
obtained by The Daily Beast alleged that
workers were troubled and frustrated by
O'Keefe's management style that he was
outright cruel to staff members project
Veritas employees said that O'Keefe
engages in berating and public
crucifixions of Staff members
um Keith is also alleged to have forced
workers to take lie detector tests to
prove they weren't leaking information
about the company
um
spat at them allegedly anyway
then it goes on I read the whole letter
it it's it's really bizarre to be honest
with you because
there's really there's nothing there's
nothing terribly salacious or
extraordinary
um there's even someone mentions in the
in the letter there's a thing about how
he took a pregnant woman's sandwich
allegedly that's mentioned too just a
bunch of weird and mostly kind of petty
complaints and all amounting to an
accusation that James O'Keefe is a jerk
basically
and um that those are that's what the
accusations come down to
and enough to
try to expel him from his own
organization
I do think the time is extremely
suspicious because O'Keefe just had a
this major bombshell exposing Pfizer one
of the most significant Scoops in recent
memory
and then and then that's when they try
to take them out
so that means that either this is being
coordinated by Pfizer somehow or it's
been coordinated coordinated by people
who are too dumb to at least hold off
for a bit so it doesn't look like it's
being coordinated by Pfizer
either the timing is directly connected
or it's not and if it's not then why
would you do it at a time when it's
going to appear to be connected
but like I said I don't know exactly
what's going on I also don't know I
don't know uh
which of O'Keefe's alleged rude
behaviors are are true if any
but I will say this
um what he's being accused of is at
worst being a jerk right that's what
he's being accused of and I'm not saying
I believe it I I don't I don't know
James O'Keefe I met him a couple times
we've texted back and forth a few times
seems like a nice guy to me
I've never heard anything to the
contrary
but my point is
I'm actually perfectly willing to
believe
that he could be a jerk sometimes and
not because I get that vibe from him
um no that's not the point
but because he's doing great things
and he's a high achiever
and high Achievers who do great things
historically you know can be jerks
sometimes in certain situations
like great
men the people who get things done uh
Visionaries which James O'Keefe is I
believe it's these people have quirks
sometimes they can often be they can be
difficult to get along with on a
personal level
there's nothing unprecedented about that
again I don't know if that's the case
with James I have no idea
but it could be simply because he's one
of the uh get stuff done kind of guys
and if that is true so what
that's the price of having a a
person like that leading your
organization and it's the only reason
why your organization exists or has
achieved all the the great things that
it has it's a price well worth paying
um
like you're not going to get a great
person who does great things and is a
Visionary and achieves High achiever and
who also gets along with everyone all
the time and everything is perfect and
he has no weird quirks about his
behavior and he never you know uh has a
bad temper like that doesn't exist
you're not going to find that
so you could find someone who's a little
bit more gentle in their behavior and a
little bit easier to get along with but
they're not going to have that greatness
High achiever fact factor to them
so I support James O'Keefe 100 that's
all that to say all that boils down to I
support 100
um and uh you can't have project Veritas
without him he is Project veritas
and so I really hope that whatever's
going on they can they can work it out
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it's proudly
veteran-owned employs a us-based
customer service team and employ and
absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks not to mention Pure
Talk service is fantastic they're one of
the largest networks in the country and
you can get blazing fast data talk and
text for as low as 30 a month probably
half of what you're paying for Verizon a
t or T-Mobile Pure Talk the no contract
Wireless company is the only Wireless
company to offer a 100 money back
guarantee on your first month don't get
locked into a multi-year contract with
huge penalties switch over to Pure Talk
in as little as 10 minutes while keeping
your phone and your phone number your
first month is guaranteed risk-free so
try it and if you're not completely
happy with the service you'll get your
money back this year make it a goal to
support companies who support you go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Walsh
should say 50 off your first month
that's puretalk.com promo code walls
your talk is simply smarter Wireless
Jerry s says Matt covertly sending the
SBG after Caleb Hammer is just too good
was it covert was it was it actually
covert I think it was sort of overt uh
but sending after you know that's not
the way that I would phrase it again
just people if there were any concerned
citizens that had feedback or questions
I was simply providing them the
opportunity
to deliver that feedback and answer
those questions I had no idea that Caleb
Hammer would
um would would not be welcoming to that
I I had no idea I thought that he would
want that
really
uh Ray Parker says I just called
hemmer's office and they hung up on me
after I asked the question so brave
and the question by the way you know so
there's a new question now I mean what
is a woman that's a great question to
ask that's still that's still a question
still the question a lot of ways but I
think there's a new there's a new the
question
um especially when it comes particularly
to this issue of how it affects kids can
a 16 year old girl meaningfully consent
having a body parts removed
and that that is the question right and
anytime you get enough you ever get an
opportunity in front of a Democrat
lawmaker or even anybody on the left
who's supporting this ask them that
question and I would phrase it exactly
like that can a 16 year old girl
meaningfully consent to having her body
parts removed
can she
because I will submit to you
that nobody on that side especially
anyone with any kind of prominence and
especially if they're on camera or being
if it's being documented they cannot
answer it they know they can't
so that should be the question that we
ask
um Ryder says I started taking steroids
at 22 after learning about the potential
sterility that can occur from using them
my 22 year old brain decided it wasn't a
big deal because I was sure that I would
never want kids four years later I
became Catholic stopped taking steroids
and started taking recovery drugs like
HCG and a desperate attempt to undo the
potential damage I'd done to myself from
years of testosterone injections my view
of wanting children did a complete 180
thanks be to God my wife is currently
pregnant with our first hopefully of
many I can only imagine how painful it
will be for these kids in 10 years when
they snap out of the delusion and
realize that it really is too late for
them and the damage is done well
congratulations to you and I'm glad that
you were able to reverse the damages
that were done and the fact that you
yeah look
I didn't take steroids when I was 22 but
um
it's the kind of thing like it if I if I
had gotten really really into sort of
gym culture and the Jim bro thing at the
age of F22 I I may have done that as a
22 year old like you're only you're 22.
yeah
you're an adult but you do a lot of
really stupid and impulsive things and
you're not
thinking about the future and especially
if you're a man at 22 and you're not in
a serious relationship then you're
you're probably not thinking much about
having kids and you PR and just like I
when I was 22 I couldn't even imagine
I can remember being 22 and thinking
about
the possibility of having kids sometime
in the future
and I just I couldn't wrap my head
around it like what I have a kid myself
as a dad that's like it's absurd
um
and so if there was some I can't even
imagine what I don't know what it would
be in an analogy but if there was
something that I really wanted uh and so
and the deal was someone said to me well
you can have this thing but uh then the
deal is like this with this Genie that
I'm talking to that you have to give up
the ability to have kids in the future
at 22
I probably would have said oh yeah I'll
take that deal
at 16 I definitely would have taken it
and then by 25 I had kids so
things change radically and drastically
as you get older
um
that's just the reality
let's see
uh
go chasing waterfall says I love your
approach Matt I've been uh taking I've
taken to using your method of asking a
very simple question to have left us
explain their important views and never
are they able to do anything other than
back away like cowards or pivot to
something totally unrelated
uh yeah well the questioning sort of
approach is uh I certainly didn't I
wouldn't call it my Approach like I I
didn't invent this I didn't invent the
idea of asking your opposition questions
to getting that trying to get them to
clarify their own position but it is
I think Far and Away uh the most
effective method especially these days
dealing with the modern left where they
they truly can't Define any of the words
that they use that that's the truth
um everything is malleable everything
has to be because this is this is the
consequence of
of being a relativist
and so
when you demand that they
we say kind of the what is approach what
is that what is that
use this word what does that mean
they'll try to treat it like semantics
they'll treat it like it doesn't matter
but but of course that's absurd
the meaning of the words that you're
using to convey your position that can't
be semantics like I can't we can't have
a conversation until I understand what
you're trying to convey
so yeah as I said I think that this is a
this is a a method that I would love to
see people use more and more training
company will be hosting a live Super
Bowl watch party this Sunday for Super
Bowl 57 you can join the live stream at
6 PM Eastern 5 p.m Central on YouTube at
Daily wire plus to get in-depth analysis
and live betting tips without all the
woke commentating head on over to Crane
and Company's YouTube page like And
subscribe and be sure to tune in this
Sunday also to celebrate uh President's
Day this year the daily wire is
launching our president's for sale sale
with 40 off new annual memberships the
big guy got 10 well we're going to give
you 40 get access to the world of daily
wire plus with Fearless documentaries
gripping movies Dennis prager's the
master's program in the entire library
of Dr Jordan Peterson's work including
his new productions like Exodus and
logos literary literacy all available to
watch right now coming down the pipeline
to a TV or laptop near you there's new
episodes of Ben Shapiro's the search
Exodus part two and then our much
anticipated DW kidscon tent and then
Pendragon later this year year to
sweeten the deal we're also giving you
up to 40 off select items in the daily
wire shop all of that if you take
advantage of our president's for sale
sale today just go to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today
that's dailywire.com subscribe now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
a few weeks ago Vice held a panel
discussion with young Asian Americans
um and here's how they describe the
point and theme of the conversation
what does it mean to be Asian in America
from hate crimes to the model minority
myth to affirmative action a politically
divisive panel hashes out the most
controversial issues facing the aapi
community today
now this is the kind of discussion
especially with hosted by Outlet like
Vice that is nearly certain to be
excruciatingly boring and Annoying It's
already guaranteed that the panel will
be stacked with leftists and leftists
are ideologically required to never say
anything remotely interesting especially
when the subject has anything to do with
race or ethnicity
but fortunately for the viewers there
was at least one young man who managed
to make it onto the panel despite having
a mind of his own a Twitter user named
Calum posted a couple of videos
featuring this man Vince is his name and
his contributions to the conversation
are quite interesting the clips are
revealing and instructive and also kind
of hilarious not because of what Vince
says I mean what he says is is good and
is correct
uh but there's nothing hilarious about
saying something that's true what makes
it funny is because of how the other
people on the panel react to him saying
those things so watch this
assimilation is it a good thing is it a
bad thing is is it a burden is it an
opportunity I think assimilation is not
just a great thing it's a necessary
thing huh no Society can hold together
where people have nothing in common they
don't speak the same language they don't
practice the same things and you know
you may look at something like just food
habits or what you eat and think that's
fairly frivolous but the truth of the
matter is that on a broader level when
we're talking about more big picture
things differences in race culture
religion all these things the people
have fought Wars violent Wars killed
each other over these things for
thousands of years if America is to hold
together assimilation not just good or
bad necessary I don't think it's going
to be possible for America to survive as
a stable functioning Society if people
don't to some degree say well here's
what we're going to commonly agree upon
but who gets to choose it the majority
culture I suppose and what's the
majority culture people with power and
who's people with power people with
power white people well I don't I don't
know
it's okay it's okay I don't know if
that's necessarily so true I mean wait
can you um yeah I don't let's
collaborate I don't think a particularly
white quote-unquote interest controls
things like in America culture do you
believe white supremacy exists I think
there are people who believe in and I
think there's people who all believe
that their race is superior so you don't
believe in white supremacy do you
believe America is a white supremacist
State no
not at all interesting and not found no
white supremacist state would even like
allow us to be doing this like I don't
understand so white supremacists this is
KKK people walking actually I go around
New York City I notice that like I guess
Brooklyn a little bit different most of
the people here are not white and
they're doing their thing so I don't
know what does doing their thing mean to
you going to work are they making words
are they making the same amount of money
I gotta say I like this Vince guy I mean
I like it for all the reasons that
everyone else on the panel is shocked
and horrified by him first of all his
point about assimilation is obviously
correct a nation must be bound together
United by more than just the simple fact
that all of its people exist inside the
same geographical boundary that's even
more the case today when the
geographical boundary is so porous and
apparently according to this
Administration negotiable
we have so we have to have something
else holding us together
to be a people not just people but to be
a people we must have a shared culture
shared values share traditions a shared
language without those things you end up
with uh fracturing and division that
leads to violence and that leads to
chaos and dysfunction
all of which we're experiencing today
of course everyone else in the room is
offended by this notion mostly because
they're conditioned to be offended by it
these are automatons operating based on
their programming it's also why the
obnoxious girl in the front row has
purple hair you know she can't help but
become a parody of herself it's like why
do these these obnoxious liberal women
why do why even do the purple hair
anymore you you're you're because you
are willingly making yourself into a
stereotype into one of the most mocked
stereotypes in existence right now you
are saying I'm going to be that person
but it's all programming
and she is aghast that Vince would
suggest assimilating with the majority
culture because she claims the majority
culture is white and she sees white as
automatically bad and she holds this
view even while telling herself that she
is not the racist one
she along with her along with her
leftist cohorts are also scandalized
that Vince will not label America a
white supremacist state but as he points
out if America was run by violent white
supremacists who control everything
the first thing they'd probably do is
stop you from pointing this out
okay
like this is a pretty good indication so
if you want to know do do I live in a in
a white supremacist violent State well
can you stand anywhere can you go
anywhere and just say this is a violent
white supremacist State and nothing
happens to you
oh no no sorry that's not nothing
happens to you you can go anywhere and
say that and you'll be applauded
well if that's the case then you don't
live in a white supremacist state
because non-white people can say and do
whatever they want and they can condemn
white people all they want without any
repercussions whatsoever unless as
repercussions you count again Applause
it's not exactly what you'd expect a
white supremacist dystopia to operate
that's not how you expect it to operate
like if you didn't know anything about
this country if you did you're crawling
out of a cave and someone told you
oh you know uh I got some bad news for
you you know you crawled out of a cave
into a white supremacist State you you
just so you know you live in a in a
systemically racist white supremacist
State when you hear that
and you don't know anything immediately
your mind is going to conjure all kinds
of images and you're going to make all
kinds of assumptions about what sort of
country this is and then you're going to
get out into the world and you're going
to find that wow it's not anything like
that at all in fact wow there's like
there's there's non-white people all
over the place running around talking
about how much they hate white people
and then there are other groups of
people there are white people following
behind them applauding
well that's not the kind of white
supremacist State I was expecting
though I do have to admit the guy at the
end was on to something he asked whether
non-whites make the same amount of money
as whites and the answer is no they
don't that's true
because most of the people in that room
in fact belong to ethnicities that make
more more money than white people on
average
many Asian immigrants come to this
country and quickly find themselves in a
higher income bracket than the average
white family the median household income
for Asians in general is a hundred
thousand dollars for white households
it's 77 thousand dollars
this remains perhaps the most
Inconvenient Truth of all inconvenient
truths for the race Hustlers because if
America is a systemically racist country
systemically racist against non-whites
how could it possibly be the case that
many non-white communities fare better
than whites
in fact Vince always on the ball makes
this very Point later in the discussion
listen
statistically it is true that Asians
right on average make more money like in
terms of medium make more money better
test scores get into better colleges all
that stuff I think the question is why
is that and I don't know if model
minority whatever that label wants
that's actually a myth because we cannot
be um well no listen well let me finish
my point we need to observe what makes
people successful and unsuccessful and I
think when you look at trends that are
generally true in the Asian Community
not of everyone but are generally true
usually you have families that are
sticking together you have
um you know people are taught to work
hard in school not get into trouble I
think that translates to why Asians on
mass are successful and I don't think
you have to be Asian or white for that
matter to not have kids out of wedlock
not you know commit crime not not cause
trouble or whatever it is it's just a
matter of like well common sense that's
what makes people successful and if
that's so-called assimilation having a
nuclear family buying a house going to
school whatever it is then yeah okay
call me a pro assembly then I think
there's a difference between
assimilation and Erasure yes
now needless to say Vince is once again
completely and irrefutably right Asian
Americans do very well in this country
they also tend to have intact families
this is not a coincidence in fact if you
look at a ranking of median household
income by race and then you look at a
ranking of divorce rate by race and out
of wedlock Birth by raise the lists are
identical okay the groups that are less
likely to get divorced less likely to
have out of wedlock births are also less
likely to be poor as the rates of broken
homes increase the rates of poverty
increase between whites blacks Hispanics
and Asians
the black community is the poorest it's
also the community with the most out of
wedlock births and broken homes the
statistics here again are irrefutable
the only crime that Vince committed was
noticing it
and as we've seen time and time again
one of the great moral crimes in our
culture today one of the only moral
crimes is the crime of noticing
like we all know that black people as a
group generally fare The Worst by every
societal measure pretty much we also
know that as a group they have the
highest rates of single-parent
households and kids raised with without
stable and reliable Parental Guidance we
all know all of that but but these are
facts we're supposed to keep on the
peripheral you're not allowed to turn
your head slightly to the side and look
directly at them
and if you do look at them you certainly
are not permitted to draw any
connections or form any conclusions and
if you do look at the facts and you form
conclusions they certainly better not be
conclusions that would even to the
slightest extent put the onus on the
black community to improve its own
situation okay you better not be
implying or suggesting or God forbid
outright saying that the black community
can do certain things itself to improve
its own position like for example have
kids get get married before you have
kids and then stay married like you're
not allowed to ever say that so I just
did
that's the greatest heresy of all
of course the other people in the room
reacted as you would expect those in a
religious cult to react to heresy if
you're only listening to the audio
you're not going to be able to fully
appreciate the scene because as Vince
calmly explains the benefits of having
intact families and discipline and you
know and encouraging education the other
panelists were they were left
slack-jawed you know they they stared in
horror their mouths a gape they shook
their heads they could not believe what
they were hearing they were in close
proximity with common sense perhaps for
the first time in their lives and they
found that the experience was was
terrifying
that to me is always is the most
disturbing thing yes obviously Vince is
right about everything he said obviously
the other panelists are wrong but it's
not just that they're wrong okay you can
be wrong about stuff it's just that they
they it's and it's not just that they
they don't agree with Vince's Common
Sense data-backed analysis of the
situation
it's really that they it's it's that
they were shocked by the analysis okay
it's one thing to be wrong to
misinterpret it to misread it but you're
shocked by it
it's that they apparently had never
heard anything like it before
it's one thing to disagree with an
obvious truth it's another to be stunned
by it
and that speaks to the suffocating
stifling bubble that these people have
been living in they clearly believe uh
what they believe merely because it's
the only belief that was ever presented
to them and they lack the intellectual
curiosity to survey the other options
they have nearly totally insulated
themselves from everything that might
challenge their worldview so when it
does happen
and they finally and by accident
encounter such a challenge they
practically faint like damsels in
distress
and that's what we saw there
and it's why Vince is not canceled today
in fact I just found out as I Was
preparing the segment that Vince has his
own YouTube channel which you can find
if you search Vince Dow d-a-o on YouTube
and you should look him up he's
obviously a brilliant guy uh the same
cannot be said for the others in the
room and that is why they are today
canceled that'll do it for the show
today as we move over to the members
block you become a member and use code
walls to check out for two months free
on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you on Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you